cleveland browns also poised to make
news reportedly close to a deal with
miles garrett the first overall pick in
the 2017
draft patrick mahomes has gotten his
10-year extension garrett according to
nfl media looking at a five-year
125 million dollar extension that's 25
million per year in new money
we'll have to look very carefully at the
structure at the guarantees the three
main factors signing bonus full
guarantee at signing and cash flow the
first three years i'm always deal not
good on any of those three counts in
comparison other great contracts oh and
he still signed for nine years after
that we'll see how good the miles
garrett deal
is and anytime any of these big deals
are getting done
in a pandemic it's impressive
and and also it makes me
it makes me think the deal had better be
damn good for the team because with all
the uncertainty
it's hard to cough up huge money and
maybe you could argue miles garrett
should have played it out a little bit
but we'll wait and see number one when
the deal becomes final number two
what the details actually are we learn
time and again not to get infatuated by
those initial reports that make the deal
seem
bigger
and more impressive
and better for the player than maybe it
really is when we have a chance to fully
scrutinize it but at least for now the
two sides working toward a deal that
would keep miles garrett in cleveland
for up to seven more seasons if they
choose to keep him around once it gets
to the year to year
team option that usually unfolds after
the first few years of a contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports